what has it been like watching your
child
become a rock star fantastic
awesome amazing amazing
wonderful all of the above yeah what's
tonight like
the pride inside is you you know i know
you're used to this now
but what does it feel like to a grammy
nominated artist the sky is the limit as
he's always been told
and he's reaching that and i'm looking
forward to him to continue
to reach and surpass hmm i love that
how much fun is it to grab your mom and
walk this is what it's all about yeah
that's right it's all about me yeah i i
enjoy her being able to you know enjoy
the experience more than i do myself so
you know that's what it's all about with
me you know how many people stand in
their their
their house and they stand in front of
mirror and they're like one day i'm
gonna take my mom on the show
did you do that yeah i was one of them
you know the second that i decided i was
gonna start rapping i actually have a
song
where i mentioned what i'm gonna say hit
the grammys you know what i mean yeah
and i mentioned you know my mother
ethnic grammy so it's just dope to just
see it all coming to fruition
it is amazing rockstar is a one of the
themes one of the anthems of this last
year what's it been like to watch that
song blow up
in the midst of a pandemic i mean it's
just you know nothing short of a
blessing not sort of a blessing you know
a lot of people froze i'm releasing new
music you know yeah but so here we press
the button and we still put that music
out still gave fans what they needed and
ended up giving people
a much needed song you know what i mean
during these hard times so
you know we just blessed to you know be
able to push that to the culture and
give people something to latch on to
it feels like you were on or collabed
with everybody this year i mean
was there anybody you missed was there
anybody you wanted to work with that you
didn't get a chance
um yeah i mean it's a lot of it's a lot
of great people a lot of great artists
that i haven't got the opportunity to
work with yet you know but
we just you know we don't force anything
we all about timing and things coming as
they want to come it definitely feels
like i did a thousand features you know
but shout out to arnold taylor
you know i mean for keeping them coming
in you know what i mean the big looks
only yeah
we do over here hey um you win a grammy
tonight where does it go
she think it's going to her house but
you know
what decide i ain't going don't put me
on the spot like that no but it looks
like
it's put me on you you already have a
place right you
gave her one of my other awards all
right yeah i may have to you know if i
i'd bring this one home tonight ma we
just alternate you get it one month at a
time
and i get it one month at a time
there'll be more than one don't worry
there'll be more than one
just look at it that way there you go
okay what does it mean to stand on that
grammy stage and get to
perform tonight because this is the
music's biggest stage not for sure it's
a beautiful thing it's a beautiful thing
i feel like it's the type of stage you
know my talent deserves to be on so
it's just always a blessing just to be
able to display the showcasing on the
platform that it's made for
i love it and you also i love that you
cleaned up everything with jojo siwa
y'all
yeah for sure man that my baby loved
that's how i know who joe joe cy is from
buying all this stuff for my baby so you
know we one thousand percent joe joe cy
fans we love i
actually reached out to see if she
wanted to perform
with me at the grammys yeah absolutely
but i heard she's
somewhere working on a project of her
own i won't say too much i don't want to
put a business out
okay somewhere filming something though
but i'll definitely reach that tell me
about the hats real quick
oh man keith james you know shout out
shout out to my boy keith and james yes
my mom my mother has on the uh the
mustard yellow with the
with the red underlay you know
complimenting her dosha and gabana
a custom handmade dress along with the
doshan gabana clutch bag and the
doshanka bunny shoes and you know mines
it's
you know it's green with the red up
under there as you can see
i got it yeah it may be a pandemic but
you were coming oh absolutely you were
coming tonight right they're gonna see
this
i love it i love the cosplay so listen
congratulations
good luck tonight i appreciate you thank
[Music]
you